hey what's going on guys it's jake and
today i'm going to be showing you all
how you can get your hands on the mimic
tier summon which is probably the most
powerful summon you can get in the game
right now i'd really recommend getting
this as soon as possible before from
software patches it because it is
extremely overpowered the first thing
you're gonna have to do is beat radon
this opens up an entirely new area of
the game that you only get access to
after you do beat radon you can go to
red main castle to do that at a certain
point in your playthrough once you do
beat radon you will see an entirely new
area that you can actually see from the
first step which is those giant floating
rocks right over there i think it is so
cool that certain boss fights open up
new areas of the map in such creative
ways in this game it's it's so cool once
you get to the giant floating rocks
you'll see a safe spot that you can jump
down to right over here and we are going
to be going down into the crater if you
hang a left from the rocks down this
hill it'll make much easier access to
start making your way down into the
crater hop down here making sure to be
very careful because you can die jumping
down here and you'll see this cave
entrance right up here just make your
way down you won't get any fall damage
and you will find the lost city of
nocron in the eternal city you'll just
make your way through this area very
normally and you'll eventually find a
rest spot here make your way through
this area as well i would recommend
exploring this area since you get some
larval tears and some other really
unique valuable items but if you're just
here for the mimic summon you just
progress through this area so this boss
fight that'll be up here is the mimic
boss fight it is likely one of the
easiest boss fights in this entire game
however if you do find yourself
struggling with it there is a pro tip to
this or kind of a unique exploit you can
take off all of your weapons and gear
and then enter into the boss fight and
the mimic will copy that naked version
of yourself you can just put on all your
armor after the mimic summons itself and
it's like a two shot kill and the boss
can't even hurt you which i find sort of
hilarious you'll see a rest spot right
here after you beat the boss and then
we're gonna progress across the bridge
once you make your way mostly across the
bridge you're gonna hang a left here and
go down the main road again don't have
to deal with these enemies if you don't
want to you'll see this singing lady up
at the top of the hill there we're gonna
take this path and then hang a left up
here you will find a spot of grace to
sit at and we want to progress down into
the city you'll just kind of make your
way across these rooftops again really
try and not fall to your death that's
pretty easy around here make your way
across this path i think this is the
only way to get down there there's a
unique item at the top of the stairs
here make your way across the rooftops
again you're gonna shimmy across this
kind of broken wall here to this other
building across the way jump down into
the building you'll kind of hang a left
and you'll see this opening right here
so this will be closed to you unless you
have a stone sword key which you only
need one to open up this fog gate and
you can deal with this one enemy
[Music]
the mimic tier summon is right in this
chest you can upgrade your summon to
make it even more powerful by talking to
the red hooded woman in the round table
she does change clothes and hair
actually so i'll show you what she looks
like now just in case she looks
different to you she looks like this and
her name is rodrika just kind of
exhausts their dialogue and you'll be
able to upgrade with her so hopefully
this video was helpful and i'll see you
in the next one boys peace and love